[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter theory in
this video we're going to be discussing
Lord Voldemort and a little object that
we know called a time Turner Lord
Voldemort was the darkest and most
feared Dark Wizard of all time and
during his initial rise to power
he left destruction in his wake the
first visiting war was responsible for
the death and destruction of many good
witches and wizards and it wasn't until
Voldemort stumbled into the Potters
humble home in Godric's Hollow that his
reign of terror finally ended it was
Halloween in the year 1981 and Voldemort
seeking out the Potters in an attempt to
stop civil Trelawney's prophecy from
coming true traveled there with one goal
in mind
killed a boy when he entered the Potter
residence he quickly put an end to James
Potter and then started making his way
towards Lille and baby Harry one outcome
that I'm sure of all the Mort didn't
predict that night was that he would be
defeated Voldemort mentioned to Lily
that if she stepped aside and let him
have Harry that he would spare her life
she obviously refused and was
subsequently murdered by Voldemort Avada
Kedavra when Voldemort next advance
towards Harry he let out one final Avada
Kedavra hoping to put an end to the boy
however what Voldemort didn't know was
that Lily had placed a loving sacrifice
on Harry an ancient and powerful form of
magical protection when Voldemort used
avada kedavra it instantly rebounded and
was deflected back at him this marked
the end of the first Wizarding war and
the end of oddball de Mort at least for
a time at the time of his initial defeat
witches and wizards throughout the
Wizarding World rejoiced at the prospect
of his demise thinking that it was the
end of Voldemort forever however what
people didn't know is that while
Voldemort's physical form was destroyed
he remained alive he was bodyless and
powerless but his lifeforce was
untouched the result of his Horcruxes 14
years later in the year 1995 the return
of the Dark Lord was official when
Voldemort was finally able to be
restored to a proper physical form in
which he brihat aimed his full magical
power
Voldemort finally getting his body back
was the result of the regeneration
potion a potion consisting of bone and
father flesh of servant and blood of foe
Wormtail helped Voldemort source these
ingredients and brew the potion
Baltimore having his physical form back
meant that the Wizarding World was back
at square one the darkest Wizard of all
time had returned was getting stronger
by the day and they no longer had the
Potters around after getting his body
back Voldemort once again caused all
sorts of turmoil in the Wizarding World
effectively marking the beginning of the
second visiting war after a few more
years of murder oppression and a general
sense of unease amongst witches and
wizards Bulldog is eventually defeated
by Harry Potter during the Battle of
Hogwarts this marked the definitive end
of audible
so the first Wizarding war began in the
year 1970 and the second Wizarding war
ended in the year 1998 that marks 28
years of a looming dark presence
upsetting the Wizarding World sure
people thought that he was gone for a
while but he came back they just had a
bit of a break we know how Harry Potter
ends and we know that Voldemort is
unsuccessful in securing a shroud of
Darkness over the world but that doesn't
mean that he didn't cause a lot of grief
surely with the advent of all of these
special magical potions spells and
technologies there must have been
someone or something that could have
helped the good guys more effectively
address this
Voldemort problem something like oh I
don't know a time Turner a time Turner
is a magical device manufactured by the
Department of mysteries that is used for
time travel given the potential
usefulness of a time Turner which allows
for time travel one might expect that
this technology would have been used
more in the fight against evil so why
wasn't it in theory after the Ministry
of Magic recognized how dangerous a
young Tom Riddle would become couldn't
they have used a Time Turner to stop him
before he oh I don't know created
Horcruxes how about before he formed an
army of Death Eaters what about as soon
as he was born before we get into this
we need to recognize the distinct
differences between the two types of
time Turner's
the first type of time-turner is called
a typical time-turner it has been stated
that the number of times that someone
turns the hourglass on this time
Turner's timepiece directly corresponds
to the number of hours that you can
travel back in time however this time
Turner is limited in that you are only
able to travel back a maximum of five
hours this is to protect the user and
preserve the fabric of time in the 1993
school year McGonigle gifts the time
turned to Hermione
so that she is able to attend additional
classes Hermione's immense workload
finally seemed to be getting to her
every night without fail Hermione was
seen to be in a corner of the common
room several table spread with books
Aerith men see charts rune dictionaries
diagrams of muggles lifting heavy
objects and file upon file of extensive
notes she barely spoke to anybody and
snapped when she was interrupted
each of these typical time Turner's has
an inscription that reads I mark the
hours everyone nor have I it outrun the
Sun my use in value unto you a caged by
what you have to do in the year 2020
more advanced time Turner's were
introduced that allowed Lea used to stay
in the past for as long as they want and
returned at the future whenever they
want these time Turner's referred to as
true time tenants and were created by
Theodore not while he was working for
lucius malfoy
so in theory the first type of time
Turner the typical time Turner wouldn't
be able to stop Voldemort because it
doesn't even have the capability of
bringing someone back that far I mean
sure it could definitely still be useful
but as far as stopping Voldemort at
childhood is concerned that's basically
off the table which brings us to the
second type of time ten the true time
Turner which we know can bring people
back as far as they want for as long as
they want right off the bat this sounds
like good news great you can just use
this time Turner go back as far as we
want and we can stop Voldemort before
everything blows up however there are
equally as many issues actually no there
are way more issues with this time too
technically it would work but you would
never use it for something like this
here's why according to Professor Saul
croaker who has spent his entire career
in the Department of mysteries studying
time magic as our investigations
currently stand the longest period that
may be relived without the possibility
of serious harm to the traveller or to
time itself is around five hours we have
been able to encase single hour reversal
charms which are unstable and benefit
from containment in small enchanted our
glasses now may be worn around a witch
or Wizards neck and revolved according
to the number of hours the user wishes
to relive all attempts to travel back
further than a few hours have resulted
in catastrophic harm to the witch or
wizard involved it was not realized for
many years why time travelers over great
distances never survived their journeys
all such experiments have been abandoned
since 1899 when L was mint humble became
trapped for a period of five days in the
affor Tino - now we understand that her
body had aged five centuries in its
return to the present and irreparably
damaged
she died in st. Mungo's Hospital for
magical Madol disease and injuries
shortly after we managed to retrieve her
what is more her five days in the
distant past caused great disturbance
the life paths of all those she met
changing the course of their lives so
dramatically that no fewer than 25 of
their descendants banished in the
present having been unborn essentially
time donors are not a reliable way of
affecting the past without the
possibility or actually more like
extreme likelihood of causing dire and
entirely unpredictable consequences in
the present entirely removing the
existence
four-figure like Voldemort would cause
presumably massive ramifications a term
in chaos theory that references this is
called the butterfly effect which is the
sensitive dependence on initial
conditions in which a small change in
one state of a deterministic nonlinear
system can result in large differences
in a later state or as Professor Salk
roca so eloquently puts it just as the
human mind cannot comprehend
so it cannot comprehend the damage that
will ensue if we presume to tamper with
its laws and that's why defeating
Voldemort wasn't as simple as just
turning back time
JK Rowling has actually expressed
concern surrounding her introduction of
time Turner's and the notion of time
travel in her books and said the
following in an interview I went far too
light heartedly into the subject of time
travel in Harry Potter and the Prisoner
of Azkaban while I do not regret it
it opened up a vast number of problems
for me because after all if Wizards
could go back and undo problems where
were my future plots she continues I
solved the problem to my own
satisfaction in stages firstly I had
Dumbledore and Hermione emphasized how
dangerous it would be to be seen in the
past to remind the reader there might be
unforeseen and dangerous consequences as
well as solutions in time travel
secondly I had my knee give back the
only time Turner ever to enter Hogwarts
and thirdly I smashed all remaining time
Turner's during the battle in the
Department of mysteries
removing the possibility of reliving
even short periods in the future this is
just one example of the ways in which
when writing fantasy novels one must be
careful what one invents for every
benefit there is usually a drawback time
travel is a vastly complicated subject
that deserves a lot of consideration and
I think that it may have been slotted
into the books and films just a little
bit hastily anyway that's it for this
video I hope that this answered the
question if you guys enjoy the content
please remember to subscribe to the
channel and like the video until next
time your Harry